attention cette vidéo comporte des
crises beaucoup de cris jeta palop papin
ni bonjour ce qui se passe là pourquoi
pourquoi il y avait déjà des trucs qui
font peur tyco est le mec quand il
marche et ce qu est ce qu un drap quoi
j'me même pas rentrer dans l'asile que
mon cas sion il prône jachère ah bah
c'est super coucou deal à l'isle adam
white a ok attentat à la bombe à l'aise
la boîte si c'est que cet homme
cherchait céréales peut-être je sais pas
il faut un grand petit déj là bas pas
d'accord vous passez par là de manière
extrêmement poussé ma faute je ne fais
plus jamais ça tam et c est ce que c'est
je prends une nouvelle tendance voilà
cependant par les pieds comme ça sans
problème montré dans mon sac de boxe
wamen ok je te disant bon je te disant
proches comment je peux tu as un mec
n'est pas mort quoi ôter mais chuck
norris tu est finalement mort moi ta
faute mais j'ai pas rêver y avait bien
un mec là et ben avait un mec y avait la
veille avait un mec bon ben on va
continuer y avait un pétale mac je ne
suis pas faux bond de bakar est ce que
t'as pas vu le mec était là pas du tout
va et toi non oui continue c'est trop
pure ouate affrontements y avait un mec
dégueulasse mais ce que c'est pas le
moment de chanter tu te calmes tout de
suite
grosse ambiance est ce que ces moments
de danser
pourquoi pourquoi personne n'a tête quoi
est-ce qu'ils étaient tous moches et qu
un dangereux psychopathe qui n'aiment
pas les mois j'ai passé par là je ne
sais pas nous sommes aujourd'hui avec
francis pascal un décédé depuis 20
minutes
qu'est ce qu'il ya de l'autre côté
francis dit nous dînons francis où j'ai
fait un gros zoom sur ton oreille faut
pas le faire tourner sur lui même ou raï
watts
ok grosse soirée est ce qu'il faut un
chat peut-être ah mais je pourrais
peut-être me cacher là dedans par
contrat c'est une bonne idée ça met ma
tête dans mon saut et attend est ce que
le mec qui a mis ça dans les toilettes
étaient conscients que le trou des
toilettes étaient trop petits quoi pour
amener ça mais qu'il a dû tirer la
chasse 300 fois pourquoi ça rentre pas
or [ __ ] il a un peu un peu trop
poussée sur la bouteille au lac étals et
les portes se ferment que les casses toi
toi tu veux te battre comme ça tout ce
qu'ils pensent j'ai envie de le taper et
de l'utiliser comme sac de boxe fait un
sac de frappe je sais pas le faith
plantes de l'extrême lui il devrait pas
en avoir une sur lui latin c'est ce que
j'aime pas trop être comme ça sur les
gens c'est un peu chelou quoi excuse moi
tu es bon voilà je suis comme ça surtout
en train de chercher de cartes haye
veulent maintenant très bien
le mec accroupis derrière à casiers quoi
est ce qu'on peut dire que c'est la pire
cachette du monde
oui on y va d'un coup je propose de
danser tu viens avec de quoi à eau
par contre les espèces de choristes là
il commence à vos gueules
van gol bordel la carte d'accès et pour
fêter ça je vais vous dire que je vous
aime
howe a fêté ça avec toi j'arrive francis
et doit acheter plus ton dos on fait
aussi comme ça lâche moi lâche moi voilà
je pouvais plus la fête avec toi tant
pis pour toi voilà pour la peine je te
mets une chanson bien dégueulasse à les
voilà à un essai de danser sur ça il ya
un petit truc quand même un bon son qui
est un petit moulin [ __ ] le voilà aux
bâtards white et des bruits waterfall
j'ai vu nombre tu est fait c'est par ici
pas vrai petit cochon je retrouverai
tous tas de [ __ ]
ah ouais ah ouais allait bien on fait
recette
à thé pas d'accord non tu vas pas vu non
je suis pas là dedans c'est qu'au nom
c'est pas moi non non non ah ouais tout
à ton crâne c'est un donne mon gars
bonjour tout le monde a des bacs à un
vieux un vieux mec là bien posté ici à
activer les deux pompes et disjoncteur
principal comme telle et roger waite sac
de boxe alayan porte
michael plus discrètement s'il te plaît
à ses deux chiens il ya des bruits un
peu chez moi pas tu as fuck même en fait
on aurait pu renommée ce jeu simulation
de je me cache dans un casier savoir
c'est dans ce casier il y avait à peu
près 6 168 personnes avant moi à fahem
gajic revoir quelques mg m'a fait un jeu
propose un speedrun te faire ta gueule
au west edmonton
non tu m'as pas vu je me suis pas mis
dans ce cas ça tu m'as pas vu le nom
mais non mais comment tu m'as vu
qu'elles viennent parfois est ce qu'on
va voir ce qu'on va le voir j'ai peur de
tomber amoureux y avait pas de gros
minet j'aime gm deuxio chef tournoi
earth vous tfc watteau mais quoi qu'il
arrive par le côté du poids qu'il répare
le côté changes epide non sais pas
comment j'ai pu n'ont pas vu mais tu pas
qu'il arrive par l'asa mais [ __ ] tu
allais je suis discrètement pétards à ce
[ __ ] [ __ ] tu as he has moi ah ouais
j'en pouvais plus est un média du
courant et c'est un jeu quand tu es
quand tu fais échoppes tu vois au cas où
tu vas faire public tu reviens avec du
rap us sur échappe
il ya toujours ce petit sont pour te
remettre la pression serment du cros
fait ça non c'est pas ça que ça allait
what what
oh là là [ __ ] il m'a mis une aiguille
comme ça quoi mitis l'injecter à
lui-même parce que les huiles m'a
transpercé watts à froch même mieux sous
les toits et five mg et a retiré tombera
avec moi et là je suppose que ça veut
dire non tu vas et fermera pas c'est ça
peut-être
arrête ça à dangereux pervers mon gars
tu as ta chance que ça crée entre no 1
avec ma corpulence
tu m'aurais défoncé tu vois ça permet
saison 1 2 3 pierre feuille ciseaux je
suppose que ça veut dire pas de pierre
feuille ciseaux voilà c'est bon la
blague est finie a tu peux arrêter jeu
j'ai compris non non tu ne feras pas ce
à quoi tu penses tu me promets jason
j'ai confiance en toi jason jason non
non non non jason jason kay salle joseph
verbeeck et jason janot veux m'attaquer
kernen mois thatcher
j'ai fait tu m'avais promis est-ce que
je peux apprendre ça comme harnes un bon
gros coups d'extincteur dans la tête l'a
alors qu'est ce vous allez me faire son
créneau des reines noix de coco avec
quelques quelques poils
je crois que là bas il a peur le bec
qu'est ce qu'ils foutent et le funk tort
c'est suspect ouaip et un ouf on est
permis à la barre est ok tu joues par
ces petits studios fait un show là
actuellement cvc l'asie - tu l'as dans
l'eau niang du conte alors tu goûtes un
7 sur 10 sport au canada et voilà
maintenant monsieur obèses va vous faire
son show à les motoneiges et trouve là
qui me choque quand je monte la [ __ ]
je les sorte de spasmes et dégueulasse
watts
ah bah c'est bon c'est bon je suis
dehors d' aller aura lieu en cas
d'actualité aujourd'hui nous sommes
rendus dans l'usiné de charal
ouais mon dieu je fais au toucher la
star du seul connaît depuis quand
j'entends sa grosse respiration d'obèses
la dark vador situe à la montre toi tout
de suite tombé pas vu lucas obata c'est
bon c'est bon allez allez allez je te
laisse te laisse te laisse que dis-je
d'or en dessous c'est bon je te laisse
le lead sa technique pour moins
consommer de batteries par contre si tu
es épileptique ça peut mal finir
j'aime bolt 3,2 à jeanne d'arc nous a
vus il nous a vus nous a vu le chef paul
lechem pol fouchet molle tu coures
allées sont deux vaisseaux de veiller
sur les styles sont devait tu passes par
là bim bim bam boum
tu vas un endroit tu sais absolument pas
où c'est vite là dedans
tu fais ta ça suffit de cache cache mon
gars oh mais qu'est ce qu'il veut
c'était la mort la plus nulle de tous
les temps adam voyez je suis pas le seul
à dormir sous les lits à il est trop
évacuer l'eau en actionnant les deux
vannes hockey et la barre et le cirque
obèses fait son grand retour dans les
jeux moches il ne boit pas les rats pas
b rappaz
on ne verra pas non mais t'es pas droit
t'es pas droit n'avait pas droit
tu avais pas droit pasta dedans dépêche
toi non arrêts de cars aux arrêts oh non
enfin avoir un spasme bâtard a même pas
les coûts mais a tout à croupir mon gars
tu es un mec qui fait trois ans qu'ils
nous quittent fils du marchand canard
mais qu'est ce que tu fais là
allez je m'en bats les couilles aplomb
je m'échappe m'en bats les couilles tu
veux tu réagis avec windows on y voit un
mets ton bonnet de bain bats pas tu m'as
pas voilà il a fait demi-tour directs
n'ont pas le petit troll c'est trop gros
à qu'est ce qui est à carlos des fesses
de carlos a donc ces questions c'est dur
xxxxl au hall et xian l'échelle la plus
jouissive de tous les temps voici
quelqu'un qui teste aussi rapide est
actuellement membre wattmen vais te dire
en toute tranquillité je m'en bats les
couilles de ce que tu me dis d'accord je
vais juste me barrer d'ici alors c'est
pas comme ça qu'on dit bonjour je
converse tout dire tout de suite
peut-être la liberté et à nyon enfin
salut où est le mal et coup j'ai mal vue
hockey ait pour tous à cache-cache
d'accord c'est comme ça ici acheter
trouver basque mais ce patch mauvais
joueur nantais le petit nouveau de la
soirée et on boycotte son myspace
bon bah voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin
de cette petite compilation de pas loin
de deux heures que j'ai passé sur la
plage c'est sympa ça vous aura plu a en
tout cas il ya eu des moments un peu
effrayant oui je l'admets je me devais
de faire une vidéo si rôle casse qui est
l'un des jeux d'horreur les plus dingues
de l'année
une trêve j'espère encore une fois que
ça nous aura plus je vous souhaite une
très bonne fin de semaine on se retrouve
vendredi soir dans une nouvelle vidéo
portez vous bien toit du monde ce pays
au nom l'espoir profonde arbres tombés
des moins jeunes arbres je n'étais pas
de la plupart des sites yard donne de la
voix qui est morne et sans retenue les
visions de
combat gens leur cette épure